The theater industry is going to need
a lot more than a jug of tulkun brain
juice to gain immortality, and Avatar 2's opening
numbers aren't turning out to be the
magic sauce James Cameron hoped for.
The opening of Avatar: The Way of Water is nothing
to balk at, with the long-in-development sequel
raking in more than $400 million worldwide in its
opening weekend, per Box Office Mojo. The numbers,
however, fell below projections — some of which
had the movie topping $500 million globally.
The reason this difference matters more in 2022
is that the box office is still trying to make
a full comeback after the shutdowns that stemmed
from the COVID-19 pandemic. To achieve this goal,
the U.S. box office is relying on massive
blockbusters like Avatar: The Way of Water,
as more and more films — like Halloween
Ends — are released directly to streaming.
"But the truth is, what we really need
to focus on is getting back to theaters."
That said, must-see theatrical experiences
that promise to push visual boundaries are
still managing to find a place at the box
office. For instance, Top Gun: Maverick
stands as the year's biggest runaway success,
pulling in nearly $1.5 billion worldwide. So,
as far as the numbers stand, 2022 proved that
audiences are ready to return to cinemas. However,
2022's domestic financial receipts are
nearly 34% lower than 2019's earnings,
meaning that the box office
still has a long way to go.
For box office purists, Avatar:
The Way of Water was set to change
everything. The film was expected to
be the latest big-screen mega-hit,
a juggernaut that would pump new life into
the movie industry. But even the huge opening
of James Cameron's latest blockbuster couldn't
solve the film industry's continuing struggles.
Avatar: The Way of Water opened to approximately
$134 million domestically and $441 worldwide,
per Box Office Mojo. One sign that this
was a disappointing start was the fact that
stocks for AMC Entertainment and Cinemark both
dropped on the following Monday. Additionally,
stocks for Disney and IMAX also dropped. This
doesn't necessarily spell all bad news for Avatar:
The Way of Water as 2009's Avatar only
opened to about $77 million domestically,
before earning more than $700 million.
However, it does mean that the movie
was not the last-minute savior the
American box office needed in 2022.
So, in order to do that, Avatar: The Way of
Water will need to bring people out to the
movie theater like no other film before
it. According to director James Cameron,
the sequel has to break into the top five of the
all-time box office to even be profitable, meaning
it potentially needs to make two billion dollars
worldwide to get into the black. Cameron told GQ:
"You have to be the third or fourth
highest-grossing film in history.
That's your threshold. That's your break even."
Does a drop in share value after a
less-than-groundbreaking opening for Avatar:
The Way of Water mean that movie theaters and
Disney need to worry? Only if they want to breed
a larger sense of doom. James Cameron's sequel may
not have brought in over half a billion dollars
during its opening weekend, but it did cross that
mark effortlessly on December 20, 2022, thanks
to international markets like China, India, and
Germany. Just like the first Avatar, the sequel's
success relies on its ability to have phenomenal
legs. Cameron himself has even said that the
opening weekend shouldn't dictate his film's
success. The director told The Hollywood Reporter:
"We'll know by the third weekend. You're
not going to know by the first weekend.
'Titanic' didn't work that way.
'Avatar' didn't work that way."
However, what Cameron says is far different
from what the industry expects. It would be
foolish to speculate how much Avatar: The
Way of Water will rake in, but it's worth
noting that 2023 will be a big year for movie
theaters — so that should quell the anxieties
of shareholders. The first three months of
2023 are filled with blockbuster releases,
including the Ant-Man threequel,
Creed III, and John Wick: Chapter 4.
So, even though Avatar: The Way of
Water didn't make the biggest splash,
its large debut is still a
promising sign of what's to come.